[Musique]
oh oh oh oh oui afida turner j'aime bien
mais on tombe à des formes comme ça il
faut les montrer l'atelier trop discrète
afida qu'il déchire très très très très
près du corps mais bon si elle aime bien
comme ça j'accepte allez salut au final
[Musique]
kenny ça suit son premier fan et les
villes de belgique tout est parfait
c'est moi qui fais lui on est sorti deux
ans s'en va c'est madonna quoi like the
jets j'aurais peut-être mis plus de
choses en bas en même temps très
pratique pour la lune hausse mais 10h10
inquiet dit oh mon dieu
oula ça c'est le saut à skis aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver
abbas et le fameux défilé gucci je crois
que j'aime c'est horrible porte la tête
de sa jumelle à massacrer un soir
d'hiver en laponie au est dégueulasse la
jupe est dégueulasse le pantalon est
dégueulasse tout est dégueulasse c'est
de la merde
[Musique]
ah oui ça j'aime bien kim kardashian ces
sortes de bongo fond laissant dur la
rendre en plastique non j'suis pas fan
alors là on a une sorte de filet de
pêche mais en diamant c'est sous l'océan
mais sauf que sous l'océan elle a vu la
terre au moins elle a du brassard
[Musique]
d'obinna nav
on adore nabi saleh dans un pub ce que
généralement on la voit en décolleté
nabil a fait énormément de progrès le
petit pantalon en cuir le gros pull pour
casser le cuir
non là je dis bravo navia mal garées
[Musique]
et rihanna tout en poils intellect tm un
ton propre la plaque son joli toutes les
deux c'est très joli ça ça elle a bien
un gars c'est pas de la vraie pour pour
aller faire nos courses jeudi n'ont rien
elle est toujours bien on adore en plus
d'aller dans un hôtel ibis je reprenais
levi deux hôtels ibis à bout de x ça
c'est isabelle morini-bosc mais bon on
lui a mis un truc qui lui va pas
vraiment à isabelle tu as tout à fait
mûr pour son âge elle a un super style
la ronde et bien regarder les petites
moufles
on n'en fait plus des comme ça je suis
très fan je vous rappelle évidemment que
j'ai toujours mon blog n'hésitez pas à
venir faire un tour c'est sur les
instantanés de valérie bénaïm point com
voilà
[Musique]